the devastating earthquake in turkey and
Syria is sending shockwaves of concern
half a world away to California
these workers are retrofitting an older
Residential Building to make it more
earthquake resistant the main thing
we're doing is we've installed this wide
flange column
and it's going to be connected to this
Foundation here many such buildings were
built without enough steel to reinforce
concrete structural pillars and beams
they lack what Engineers call ductile
strength so the word ductile it yeah it
has to do with flexibility a building
has to be able to move a little bit and
concrete is really strong but it's it's
a little brittle it's not very flexible
and so having enough steel inside is
what makes it flexible because steel is
very ductile
the magnitude 7.8 turkey Syria Quake
happened in a seismic Zone strikingly
similar to the San Andreas fault which
runs through Los Angeles County home to
9.3 million people they're actually very
similar uh Quake zones or uh fault zones
Southern California is no stranger to
large earthquakes the 1994 Northridge
Quake was a magnitude 6.7 and it could
happen again in Los Angeles there are
about 1200 older buildings like this one
that Engineers say would be heavily
damaged if the city were struck by an
earthquake of the same magnitude as the
one that hit turkey and Syria
the Los Angeles County Board of
Supervisors recently voted to create new
rules requiring retrofitting of older
non-ductile buildings and to create an
inventory of vulnerable structures
experts who have modeled Quake scenarios
say loss of life in the event of a major
La Quake would be much smaller than in
turkey and Syria because of better
Construction
nonetheless there will be loss of life
and there will be some you know
destruction and people are gonna have to
rebuild it's going to be a big hit the
worst part will be the aftermath with
major highways possibly severed Electric
Power and Water pumping stations knocked
offline for weeks Los Angeles is
preparing itself but the forces slowly
grinding beneath the surface are
unstoppable Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los
Angeles